[Music]
i remember i was sitting right outside
my house when uh
my buddy told me that the co-worker
glenmart had passed away and
instant disbelief and sadness
now there's this beautiful human being
who's
who's not on the earth anymore
and then the anger came in because
because he was super concerned about
kovit
yet you know there was nothing done for
him
and his concerns kelly kohlberg worked
at dallas fort worth international
airport as a baggage handler for envoy
air
a regional carrier owned by american
airlines kohlberg and other envoy fleet
crew members were considered essential
workers
as they showed up to keep operations
running during the early days of the
pandemic
we expected certain things to be done
just basics like you and i
cleaning our own house and that wasn't
done you didn't have gloves you didn't
have
masks you had nothing there was no
social distancing
kohlberg's co-worker glenmar gabriel was
one of about 30 envoy workers
infected with coronavirus early on in
the pandemic
envoy says that at the beginning of the
pandemic it put a plan in place to
increase cleaning and sanitation
that was in line with cdc
recommendations
but even after gabriel died the federal
agency dedicated to protecting workers
the occupational safety and health
administration or osha
did not thoroughly investigate multiple
complaints against envoy
the coronavirus pandemic upending the
nation's meat industry
several processing plants have shuttered
after covert 19
spread throughout their workforce
there's also an increasing focus on
protecting essential employees
including grocery store workers at least
30 have died of the coronavirus since
the outbreak started there are more
clusters of coronavirus cases among
construction workers than any other
industry in austin
workers say they are scared for their
health and safety
worker health and safety is at the core
of osha's mission
but according to a wall street journal
investigation as
complaints surged 72 percent during the
pandemic from the previous year
the agency was caught overwhelmed and
unprepared
it's difficult to pinpoint where
infections happened and to know for sure
the role workplaces played in the spread
of the virus
but the wall street journal found that
osha left workers vulnerable to
outbreaks on the job
osha has opened formal investigations
into only six percent
of all coronavirus related workplace
complaints
that compares with 22 percent of
non-coronavirus complaints since the
pandemic began
and 32 of all complaints in the prior
year
a department of labor spokesperson says
that osha investigates all safety and
health violation allegations
within its jurisdiction the spokesperson
says that investigations can be
conducted
by phone or other modes of communication
this is
the crisis the osha was invented for but
osha hasn't
stepped up to the plate created in 1970
osha and its state equivalents are
tasked with ensuring safe conditions in
workplaces
osha is supposed to issue standards that
tell employers exactly what to do
to protect workers osha can issue an
emergency temporary standard that says
we have a new and very serious
hazard we need a protection immediately
in the beginning of osha's history
asbestos was a very common hazard
in workplaces in 1983 osha issued an
emergency temporary standard
which aim to further limit workers
exposure to asbestos
osha doesn't have any standards or
regulations that are specific to
coronavirus in a may congressional
hearing osha's then top administrator
argued that the agency had taken early
and adequate steps
to protect workers during the pandemic
osha had started as early as january of
this year
putting information on our website
through a safety and health topics page
to inform individuals about the pandemic
we outlined what standards we thought
employers should be aware of that they
should be in compliance with
and we've subsequently provided general
industry guidance along with almost 20
actual individual industry guidance
documents to help employers
respond to this pandemic that guidance
was in accordance with cdc guidelines
but experts like michael's say it wasn't
enough employers
can see ocean recommendations saying
look it's important to make sure
workers are wearing face cloth coverings
it's important that workers
are six feet apart and there's good
ventilation but unless osha requires
that of every employer
some employers are not going to do it
and that puts other employers who want
to do the right thing
and the financial disadvantage they've
got to compete with these employers
they're not going to protect their
workers
as i stand before you today we have more
than 100 coronavirus cases in the united
states clean and disinfect
frequently wash your hands with either a
disinfectant or with soap and water for
at least 20 seconds
as kovid was progressing into march and
april
the only things that we were informed
about through emails
were your prototypical cdc standard
letters that they were sending out
you'll have a supervisor come in and
they'll give their uh their morning kind
of speech you know hey be
safe and it did include you know hey
wash your hands
the problem with that was what they were
advising
um we weren't even able to do because we
didn't have the resource
you know i'm trying to wash my hands
there's no soap kolberg says in
mid-march
envoy break rooms and crew areas were
dirty some workers brought their own
soap
because dispensers were often empty as
you could see
there's no product in that soap
dispenser
and there's the alternate
envoy says that concerns raised by
employees about soap and hand sanitizer
were related to the locations that were
not part of the company's lease spaces
at dallas-fort worth airport envoy says
that when concerns were raised
it addressed the issues with the party
responsible the company says that at the
time
employees expressed concerns about masks
and gloves in march
the cdc recommended against their use
on march 16th an envoy employee filed a
workplace safety complaint with osha
it alleged envoy didn't have an
effective plan to address the specific
exposure risks
associated with the coronavirus on march
23rd
osha notified envoy of the complaint and
requested the company
investigate the alleged conditions osha
asked envoy to reply by march
30th with details about any corrective
actions
envoy responded on march 31st writing
that the company continues to
communicate cdc guidance
that rooms are frequently cleaned and
that soap and hand wipes are supplied
for employee
use the company also said flights
continue to be spread throughout the
terminal
preventing larger groups from being in
one ready room
[Music]
on april 5th glenmar gabriel died
the minute i heard he passed away
nothing else mattered anymore it was
about preventing
the potentiality of that happening to
anyone else
the day after gabriel's death a second
complaint was filed to osha
by an envoy employee this complaint
again alleged envoy did not have an
effective plan to address covid specific
exposure risks
and that it was not following cdc
guidance to protect workers
again osha asked the company to
immediately investigate the alleged
conditions
osha told envoy to respond by april 15th
it's unclear if envoy responded or if
osha investigated further
based on documents obtained by the
journal
every one of our break rooms the seating
is consist of picnic tables where you'd
have you know six
individuals at a picnic table
kohlberg decided to go to the local
media i documented about as much as i
could
i was reaching out to any anyone who
wanted to hear
on april 15th the nbc affiliate in
dallas
aired a story about the coronavirus
outbreak among american airlines
and envoy workers we have learned that
30 dfw
ramp workers at american airlines and
americans regional carrier
envoy have tested positive for
coronavirus and 26 more at
envoy are still waiting on test results
according to union officials
kohlberg says he did see improvements in
cleanliness and social distancing
right after the new story ran it was so
clean
they had a table they had ppe gloves
masks
everything they had a cdc table
for information where to get tested
everything
they had social distancing set up
different break rooms open
with tables and chairs spread out you
had
what you should have now i'm not sure
how long all that stayed but
but it definitely uh got fixed
immediately
a few days later the company fired
kohlberg
they brought me in the office and fired
me for what they claimed to be was
a violation of attendance envoy disputes
employees claims that cleaning and
coveted protocols
were enhanced immediately following the
nbc affiliate story
the company says those measures were in
place prior to the april news broadcast
the company says it doesn't want to
comment on employee disciplinary matters
but disputes kohlberg's description of
what happened
on july 9th a third complaint against
envoy was filed with osha
it alleged employees were not informed
about potential exposures
and reiterated accusations raised by
previous complaints
[Music]
again osha asked envoy to remedy the
situation
with no mention of prior complaints
about envoy
on july 24th envoy responded and it said
it had addressed the matters
raised in the complaint osha did not
further investigate
normally osha would be tracking all
complaints they certainly should get out
after the second or the third to really
see what's going on because
clearly there's concern on the part of
workers what happens after a while of
course is if osha doesn't respond at all
the workers stop complaining that's even
worse
by november 2020 the transportation
workers union
which represents envoy airlines fleet
and maintenance crews
had tallied nearly 50 coronavirus cases
and one death
among its dallas fort worth members
in total the journal identified over a
thousand covid deaths at companies
throughout the u.s that osha did not
investigate
even though workers were likely exposed
to the virus on the job
these include deaths employers didn't
report to osha
the journal identified 180 deaths that
occurred
after employees sent complaints to osha
these complaints were never investigated
by federal or state workplace safety
authorities
beyond what was often a brief
correspondence with the companies
no one suggests that different actions
could have prevented the deaths
identified by the journal
osha says that in total it investigated
and subsequently closed
six complaints against envoy air
regarding locations in a nearby
dallas fort worth airport osha says it
never received a fatality report related
to covet 19 from
envoy only after the journal contacted
osha
about glenmar gabriel's death did the
agency investigate
according to a department of labor
spokesperson osha's investigation into
the fatality
is ongoing i know osha is filled with
dedicated safety health professionals
but the leadership of osha has
essentially said
we're not going to do anything special
we're not going to issue a standard that
osha can then
apply that inspectors can go into a
workplace and say look
you're not following our regulation and
therefore will issue a citation
all those dedicated people really are
handcuffed i expected
accountability to be at a a different
level it is a new standard and so yeah
you expect that
if this person doesn't do it well you
know this entity which keeps them in
check
will do something and if they don't
someone will but
nobody nobody at any level does anything
the only people would be the people down
on the ground they're the only ones that
are looking out for themselves
you